well mike let me make you feel better
hey it's our boy
the prank it's a fight it's the point
game we got a new prank
we got a new plank oh yeah we opened a
toy store in a house
that's illegal it's against zombies
welcome back
it's a blank okay good point but then
i'm already poking holes in the plane
come on it's illegal you're ruining your
spoilers you're ruining the planks your
house is zoned residential you can't
just run a store out of your house it's
illegal
sorry it's getting ready are you are you
ready to laugh
no because you can't run a store out of
your home it's going to be buzz killings
zoning laws i get it break out the
paperwork
it says here in orange county that hang
on if you have a mixed
use permit uh filed before the fiscal
year the brain
just ruined their video brothers
everybody back at the house again
another beautiful morning but this time
not doing a prank
we woke up darius and matt yesterday for
10 million subscribers and it was pretty
insane so guys go watch our last video
right now
today i'm not doing a prank today except
they totally are
we're waking everybody up i want to set
that jacket on fire
why i don't want him to take it off
either it's pretty cool
somebody said he looks like amanda p
okay let's just go inside and check it
out
oh so the dober brothers are hiring
illegals are they illegals part of his
prank are they ms-13
are they pedophiles who do we know how
do we know how they got over here wanks
[Applause]
how can you i'm sorry i got to point
something out how can you have no
furniture and your house still be a mess
yes i can answer that question yes
because you have no furniture
that's true you see furniture exists for
you to put things in and put things on
got it and when you don't take it for me
the guy who had to wait three weeks for
[ __ ] bedroom set i had bags
everywhere and it was hell
now when i go home i go home to a very
nice neat bedroom
and everything has things in a drawer
and it's very organized i
to answer your question yes because they
have no furniture go buy some furniture
okay a curio something
[Applause]
and get some wd-40 while you're at it as
a matter of fact i guarantee those
mexicans have wd-40 in their truck
and also i don't know what it is about
people and this isn't the first time
i've seen a setup like this
where people think um
that they they buy these like really
nice ridiculous house in hollywood
and they put no furniture in it because
they just want to have the baller house
but your baller house looks like [ __ ]
without furniture in it
it looks terrible like it's it looks
like you're showing it
you know what i mean it looks like
you're doing an open house for people it
doesn't look like you
it looks like you're squatting when you
walk into those houses and they have the
fake tv
like you know the plastic one at the
show house because they don't want to
leave a real one overnight you got to
touch it and it's like oh it's
no that's not real so this is sorry
he's really waking him up
sorry you wake up bro
it's not a prank this time no
firecrackers we're good no pranks
no pranks i got a surprise wait you're
filming this early girl again
oh man i was totally actually really
just sleeping right now dude
i wasn't actually just sitting at my
computer smoking a ball i was just
oh dude oh whoa wow
did i mention i was sleeping what a
prank
it's not earlier than yesterday bro it's
8 30 a.m this time
the sun's just coming out but we're good
i got a big surprise bro oh
god is your girlfriend fake pregnant
again i hate these two
i i hate why man like i don't hate them
the way i hate other people whether
it's pure hate i i do actually get some
enjoyment out of watching these videos
but man these guys are hateable hearts
being in the kitchen
sounds good all right bro you ready
i guess no there's no one there
no pranks no pranks surprise congrats on
10 mil
once again
[Applause]
[Music]
so they got themselves toys
this also just furthers my theory that
they buy subs because
even with 10 million subs whatever
you're doing good you're making money or
whatever you're not just going to waste
all that money on toys like
youtube's not paying that much to set
this whole shot up and to set up all the
toys and
have mexicans come and [ __ ] change
your house up
like that costs money they're paying for
the subs and they're also paying for all
these gimmicks i guarantee you
these these these kids are a [ __ ]
colossal drain on their parents
[Music]
you know this goes to show you that
these these two are the these guys are
adults
but it goes to show you that this this
this is for kids like this what this
channel is pandering to they're showing
cool toys
it's just bright colors to keep the
attention
you know although i will say this i did
watch a stream last night i actually
watched a hyphonic stream
where he was uh unboxing pokemon cards
and i don't know why but i got sucked
into it for an hour
there was something about there was
something about the the opening of the
packs and and like finding out if
anything good was in it
even though i don't know anything about
pokemon cards but he was just doing the
[ __ ] he was just opening them and i
found myself like
okay i gotta find out what's in the next
pack i got sucked
it it was the weirdest thing last night
the other thing is
it's like these are shitty someone
pointed out but these are shitty
drugstore toys
yeah they're not good these are the toys
you get when you didn't get a present
for somebody
right when you when you're on your way
to somebody's house for christmas and
you go
ah [ __ ] they had a third kid this year i
forgot [ __ ] okay so maybe they're gonna
give these toys away to kids maybe
that's what the gimmick is i'm gonna
fast forward a little bit here to see
what they're doing
you know gotta bring the childhood back
you know
[Music]
yo yo what's up guys what's up guys hey
what's up alex dalen what's up what's up
what's up
bro i wasn't here earlier helping you
set this up i'm totally shocked
this is about good to see you i don't
know bro
wow freak toys maybe the point is all
the toys have covered on them
it's holiday season bro if i walked into
it like if i had a friend that was a
streamer that had money like this
and we went to his house and it was set
up like this i'd go
yeah you're cool there's like is there
any liquor or girls
like some coke around like is there you
know like is this really how we're
celebrating 10 million subs because
i was really hoping we were gonna hop on
the liquor girls and cocaine train but
yeah cool i guess a baby yoda is also
kind of cool gotta stay kid at heart you
know what i mean
from halo yeah some of these toys are uh
just be careful you know yeah yeah
because it's like you know be careful
bro
okay this is
huh that was a pretty good like new york
guy he's not from new york you don't
think
no but it was you gotta have a really
trained ear you gotta be from new york
but it was very cl it was very dead on
that's what they said regular rich
little yeah like when you go you see
like the mafia guys they always go
is it the [ __ ] down syndrome
now i think he's doing an impression of
um jake lamotta at the end of raging
ball oh okay
[Laughter]
when he's just holding his belt
oh my favorite problem
i don't think that th i don't think you
really made those noises
pretty funny dude this is pretty funny
come on man they're just being wacky bro
it's planks
[Applause]
i found the perfect two bro oh yes you
know it
why is that the perfect toy for him is
because it's a basket why are you giving
the basketball to the black guy
you should report this channel for hate
speech that's hate speech
that is straight up hate speech could
you imagine
yo deuce is playing uh some college
basketball back in the day let's go but
don't take it out of the package because
you have to return it later
that's a good point oh my god you're
right but what i don't get is he wearing
a selena shirt
oh my god i think he is no seriously is
that not is that celine that's something
right looks like selena or salinas yeah
look the s
with the e yeah it's selena
no they still got it though you still
got it yo if you guys have like young
relatives or anything too just grab a
toy and give us them right
why not really that's no bro
awesome that's dope bro thanks man
i'm not acting right now
not giving her enough cuddles bro she
wants the bear instead you know what's
good when you have to repeat the thing
over and over again
have to repeat the thing over and over
again have to repeat this all right
i don't know i see you guys hit 10 mil
congrats thank you congrats bro
you know a little party you know here
free toys little toy party kid at heart
all right oh that's legendary here we go
he's opening a pokemon cards mike you
might like this
we'll get some holographic cards like
back in the day yeah i do have a nice
collection in my room
got the holographic music the charizard
you know but i'm not
getting rid of those for another 20
years see but even when these guys open
cards i hate them
there was no i'm telling you man look i
know it sounds gay watching hyphonics
open cards but hyphonics
is kind of ocd and he did have a very
visually appealing way of unveiling the
cards like he has an overhead camera
he cuts them very meticulously open he
does like he
he has a system where i did find it
soothing maybe it was just my autism
showing but i was just i found it
soothing this guy's gonna probably rip
the pack open with his teeth and be like
hey yo bro look i got caught not even
know what any of them are
like hyphonics is like borderline
autistic so he would open a card and
then go oh man that's a reverse poi of
reverse foil
pikachu that one's worth 180 like he
knew
like you go wow this guy knows his [ __ ]
right off the fly this dude stinks
nice hey let's go
alternatives that's how long we're gonna
be doing youtube for
eternity but do you say you gotta open
one of these cyrus
you too i think someone just walked in
oh hey guys oh what's up dad
you here for the free we got a free is
that his dad for real
yeah toy shop that was a help
crazy right wow hey
did i leave my checkbook here or like
did you steal it or
cause like i just can't get it please
we got an awesome workers yeah i was
just coming in to see why there's a 27
thousand dollars charged on my amex at
kb
toys and i think i just figured it out
and i think yeah i think i'm now putting
two and two together
[Laughter]
oh okay they came in hard through the
grass
i'm going
oh that's not uncle cracker
no he's too young to be uncle cracker
he's like nephew cracker
got it okay
yo cyrus set up a free toy shop for all
of us but we only have one basketball
okay
i don't want you two fighting over it
we're stabbing each other over it or
committing violent crimes against each
other over it
and then blaming us we don't need that
sir
no way yeah finally
but i love it too they keep going bro
yeah we're celebrating so we have a toy
store anybody could take what they want
um put i'm a grown-up i don't i don't
want toys
i mean you could have found something
cooler like again
go with my idea liquor coke and girls
nobody's ever
listen nobody's ever gotten liquor
cocaine and girls into the same building
and then
invited their male friends nobody's ever
had a complaint
in in the years i've had liquor coke and
women in the same building
there's never been a guy in history you
know what i don't care for this
or or i don't care for one of these
three things you just do the other two
things like it doesn't matter
for adults liquor cocaine and women get
those every time
you'll be way cooler than the dobra
brothers
oh yeah dude i was actually staring at
that i might have to take that home
yeah mustard tiger says high end liquor
store how cool would that be
you go like rotc we're celebrating 10
million subs you walk in the house and
there's like macallan
you know what i mean and there's like
really good scotches and [ __ ]
like really good whiskies and you go
holy [ __ ]
yo guess what else we got yo we got a
bunch of [ __ ] cuban cigars and you're
like
what are you kidding me cuban cigars and
liquor
wow and steaks we got omaha steaks
as a sponsor and they sent a bunch of
steaks you'd go whoa that's adult stuff
i hope this isn't a plank
can we get good steaks instead are omaha
steaks bad i've never had one they're
not great
i've never had one they mail you steaks
to your door they're not great
well i would i would think you'd that
would be a system they could figure out
right i've had all my sticks they're
fine they're fine they're just just fine
they're just a [ __ ] stop
they're fine they're just fine by the
way that's even worse than saying
something's not good when you're
that's a real especially if somebody
cooked something and you say that to
them
it's the shittiest thing you can say
it's just fine i guess
it's past it's steak
good stuff good stuff
so i mean look the whole video is just
done playing with toys i mean it's
together what they're doing
how many views uh this one has
uh as of today 458
000. 39 000 likes
uh 39 0001
why would you do that don't do that
i just liked it that'll be part of the
problem
what do you mean part of the problem
they played with toys that was pretty
pretty cool
pretty cool